it's time now for one more thing I'm
gonna go first so there is a story over
the weekend about the serious strikes
nikki Haley the ambassador to the UN
went on the sunday shows and talked
about additional Russian sanctions take
a listen you will see that Russian
sanctions will be coming down Secretary
Minuten will be announcing those on
Monday if he hasn't already and they
will go directly to any sort of
companies that were dealing with
equipment related to Assad and chemical
weapons use those sanctions were not
announced Monday there was reports from
The Washington Post that they were
pulled back larry cudlow the president's
new economic adviser said this this
morning about nikki Haley ahead of the
curve she's done a great job she's a
very effective ambassador there might
have been some kinoma Terry confusion
about that but if you talk to Steve
management at Treasury and so forth he
will tell you the same thing they're in
charge of this we have had sanctions
additional sanctions are under
consideration but in the last half-hour
I was able to get in touch with nikki
Haley and she said quote with all due
respect I don't get confused so there is
some clarity at least from her part on
that tonight